er jetzt
lieber einfach weil es immer um gebügelt
will
die jungs etwas krankes einfallen lassen
glaubst du ich kann für einen tag bei
einladen haben könnt ihr auch schilder
für restaurants und ein rohbau du hast
doch diese riesigen friteuse oder 800
pence und trance geht klar ich bräuchte
eine riesige klatsche habt ihr die
möglichkeit so etwas anzufertigen aber
weißt du das wieder gerade gestartet
haben ich eröffne ein kostenloses
restaurant also haben wir die idee in
die tat umgesetzt wir haben den gesamten
laden ausgemessen und im anschluss
eigene designs erstellt logo speisekarte
außenwerbung t shirts verpackung wenige
tage später war alles fertig robs xxl
fritteuse für unmengen von pommes ohne
die wäre die schiere menge gar nicht
bewältigbar gewesen
verpackungsmaterialien und saucen aus
der metro
das was passieren würde es wurden nur
120 von 800 bestellten bürger band
geliefert woher kriegt man an einem tag
fast 600 prius spannend die unschöne
wahrheit ist bei ganz ganz vielen
einzelnen supermärkten und großmärkten
deshalb sind eric und ich einen
nachmittag lang rum gefahren und haben
nichts gemacht außer burger brötchen zu
holen doch dann hatten wir sie
zeitgleich kam die planzahlen und die
presse war auf uns aufmerksam geworden
und wollte zeitungsinterviews ich war
verdammt aufgeregt
[Musik]
dieser macht
draußen schon erste einfach so zu essen
und eltern alles für uns muss ja leider
filmen
gleichen
eltern viel das ist etwas gebraucht
wohin mit den schals
alles war vorbereitet doch jetzt wurde
es wirklich ernst die zu groß
[Musik]
und wer kommt aber ganz genau
aber am see gefahren cook ist dir an
bruder
und auf einmal war die anspannung weg
ich hatte ein gigantisches event auf die
beine gestellt alles war
zusammengekommen und ich musste nur noch
abliefern und das haben wir gemacht und
[Musik]
dann war da bevor wir aufgemacht haben
draußen ist schon eine fette schlange
und ich mache jetzt den ersten bürger
der erste max burger
braten
[Musik]
wer ist mallorca
das ist es das ja
[Musik]
ihr seht wie einfach das rezept ist aber
ihr seht auch mit 80 die bürger werden
die man machen kann vielleicht brauchen
wir einfach diese domain com ganz kurze
müssen wir die ersten beiden hier in der
schlange werden als wir gekommen sind
waren die schon da folglich dass ihr
hier seid wie gleich los meinte danke
dir
was sagst ja krise die sehr sehr kleine
details allem viele auf ist italien man
ja da drin auch die bilder du bist
natürlich auch die stadt ja stimmt die
bilder sind auch zu krass ist ein
richtig geiler ist geiler recap der mit
einem einfach zum feiern welche eine
million auch nennen hier ins anfang
meines videos luca natürlich vertreten
mir selbst im golfmarkt apple und
ansonsten auch ganz viele verschiedene
rassen berger geht jetzt raus für meine
beiden soldaten die erste wie daran den
allerersten burger dürft gerne schon mal
zu mir wissen auch noch die salzburger
aber
selbst ganz wimpelkette mario matt
bürger endlich ging es los die schlange
wuchs und wuchs freunde kamen vorbei
aber was wirklich abgeben
aus bis zum art und dabei bisher fast so
bis zur brücke wieder ein lebensretter
treffen uns dann wirklich zu finden
alle gekommen
er braucht
da bekommt selbstverständlich klicks als
ehrengast und nicht als
praxistest von smash wir machen immer so
einst max burger gemacht ich bin halt
richtig schnell und richtig wild das
wichtigste drauf was man braucht und
damit 110
im palast nicht sprechen danke dass ihr
zu geben gas wieviel wieder beraten
gestört es ist halt max burger könnte er
könnte also aufmachen ist komplett
er muss halt 800 bürger machen
schlagbauer lecker lecker
kennst du mal zu videos eigentlich
einem geschenkten gaul schaut man nicht
ins maul
so scheinen guter komfort bei ist schon
vorbei
eine frage nicht lange währen will einen
vegetarischen burger hände hoch
wir haben keine vegetarischen burger
mehr
[Musik]
aus wachs erst haben wir uns also nicht
wirklich max burger größten
[Musik]
richtig lecker
ob auch mehr laut faz das zusammen diese
nicht richtig geil
salzburger des blut man merkt wie fresh
express r wurde liefert einen scheck
über
software ist sehr gerne aktion auch sehr
gerne organisiert alles na also muss man
schon echt sagen den ganz groß ist
zwischen 110 eine 11 10 10 09 55 und 59
14 von 19 und jetzt ehrliche meinung
nicht fürs video ist wirklich erklärt
was für ein tag leute ich bin unfassbar
froh so viele von euch kennen gelernt
haben zu dürfen es ist unglaublich für
mich mein letztes treffen mit zuschauern
ist jahre her vor kroner vor koch
content und jetzt eine coole erwachsene
gesprächs fähige community vor sich
stehen zu haben mit dem man einfach mal
beiden kann ist das größte kompliment
was man machen kann ich bin dankbar dass
er meine videos schaut ich bin dankbar
dass wir da war es war einfach nur geil
und jetzt gibt es einen kleinen
rückblick auf die vergangenen acht jahre
schon gemacht ich war halt dabei dann
haben jetzt eben auch überlegt dass wir
ein kanal machen also mein name ist mag
ich bin 16 jahre alt ich wollte einfach
noch mal danke sagen 10.000 menschen die
wie abonniert haben zwar vor allem im
blick auf youtube ein besonderes jahr
für mich so 100.000 abonnenten erreicht
und ich bin ich unglaublich dankbar
dafür heute ist der geburtstag von
meiner kleinen schwester wer kann besser
lügen kipp die party bei welcher spülung
spritzt das wasser wie wär's mit dem
größten sneakers der welt ich habe mir
eine besorgt überraschungspaket gestellt
wie ihr vielleicht mitbekommen fließt in
den letzten monaten auch meinen kanälen
und mich wirklich rund sorgt ich habe
echt lange keinen videos gemacht ihr
könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen wie
unzufrieden nicht damit bin
herzlich willkommen zu meinem neuen
einfach als persönlicher kochen die
besten und teuersten luxus man hier
waren nämlich im besten restaurant in
düsseldorf und ich habe mich einfach nur
gefragt wie schmeckt und heute haben wir
einen pizza und einen burger spot
getestet und danke für eine million abos
da kommt noch was besonderes auf euch zu
die geschichte ist erzählt der laden ist
abgebaut eine million abonnenten danke
für diesen meilenstein danke fürs
zuschauern dax dabei sein wir sehen uns
beim nächsten video wieder macht's gut
bis dahin und schauen
[Musik]